what up guys welcome back to get close
and today we have stan fritting back
again i'm your host bart
i'm a geo i was clapping for stan i was
like yeah he's back and on the second
appearance what we like to do is to get
questions from fans
so that they can really get to know you
because we got close with you on the
first episode so now it's the fans
chance to yes if these questions suck
it's not on us let's do it i'm an open
book all right so the first one is
what's the day in the life of stan
efforting like well i'll tell you these
days it's a bit of a popcorn machine
because i've got two kids seven and nine
so i'm up early i try and get some of my
work done in the morning i'm writing
writing a book right now vertical kids
uh and so wait for that the only time
you can get that done and actually have
any
brain power left is in the morning
before that gets robbed by all of the
duties
yeah so i get up early and i'll all
right i'll try and write for an hour a
day uh six a.m okay yeah and get try and
write for an hour on that book and then
then the kids are usually get them up
uh around 7 30 we'll get them ready for
school and that's you know running
around
this morning in particular
my daughter says i need crayons i can't
go to school without crayons like
wouldn't yesterday have been a better
time to mention this yeah yesterday
would have been awesome yeah so i'm
racing over to cbs down the street to
get crayons this morning and i put the
the prep meals in the microwave and hit
the button and then i run over to the
cbs to try and get the crayons before
the meals are done
and uh and get her ready
um oh and then like 10 years ago or more
i had a um i had a tooth cracked i got a
soccer ball hit my face
and so the tooth died
and my dentist took it out took the
tooth out and put a a cap in there and
this morning as i get i eat my breakfast
with like some sourdough toast it was a
little tough the tooth pops off oh no
and i'm supposed to be in here to do a
video with you today and look like the
wicked witch of the west so i had to i'd
run over and get some super glue and
glue my tooth back on oh my god
and then yesterday was 20 rep sets on
squats and so i had a uh my eye bled
yeah from 20 rep sets on you just came
in here and said you got in a fight and
you beat up the dude no kidding i i
said something bad to my wife and she
clocked me
so
but then uh usually between the time the
kids are in school from nine to three
that's opportunity for me to uh work on
the businesses that's uh you know
obviously my ebook we just released the
vertical diet book this one here just
down barnes and noble and it's on
um amazon and so we do a lot to you know
corresponding with people i have clients
of course that i work with and um
uh we also own a meal prep company and
partnership
and we uh you know we deliver nationwide
and so we do a lot of marketing for that
and so you know like you folks would get
on social media and try and do our our
marketing for the day and you try to fit
in all the business work between the
between nine and three because when the
kids come home at three you can't get
anything done nothing oh man i'll tell
you when the schools were shut down and
they were doing the the home schooling
yeah the computers yeah they were never
in class i can't understand when they
actually
all day long it's like dad dad damn
aren't you supposed to be in class she
couldn't get anything done it was
terrible so i pick them up at three and
uh usually there's some after school
activity we we take them to kumon or
something it's a it's a math and reading
uh
education course which is extraordinary
and then some sort of athletic event if
we can now they're not in sports i had
them in mma for a while and then i had
them in gymnastics for a while they get
bored quick and so now i just take them
to places like uptown jungle fun town
and the the sky zone to you know climb
rock walls yeah as long as they're
sweating and running and jumping yeah
let's burn that energy i'm happy of
course you know i got to get my workout
in sometime during the day and um so
you're trained in the while they're at
school yeah usually while they're at
school i'll train
and sometimes see now i'm traveling i'm
my i have a client and i train out of
state and so i'm in albuquerque every
other week
and so i'm only home for a week at a
time or about 10 days and then i'm gone
for five
i just fly into albuquerque monday
morning get home friday night and and
train uh during the week and so i
haven't been home as much but
historically i used to travel quite a
bit i'd leave on friday do a seminar on
saturday come home on sunday i've done
over 200 seminars every weekend almost
every weekend yeah
the the longer ones out of country you
know i'll be gone for a week if i did
say russia or the uk or switzerland or
yeah those ones
panama
but mostly it was just a weekend deal
i'd go to canada or i'd hit in one of
the states leave on friday come back
sunday so it's kind of depends on you
know the schedule kind of develops as
things get booked but that's how long do
you train for
you know i i try not to train more than
an hour really yeah how many days a week
i try and do five days a week just crush
it and just try and crush it yeah
you could train long or you trained hard
but you can't do both and so i really i
try to keep the rest periods a little
shorter i'm not primarily focused on
strength now more bodybuilding and so i
do keep the rest periods shorter and try
and do more volume
and you know at my age i don't recover
as fast so i can't really train two a
days
like i used to and i don't have the time
for it yeah and so i'm usually super
setting say back and chest i'll do a dip
and rest for a minute and do a chin up
and try and get a lot of volume in that
way in a short period of time are most
of your workouts super sets like the
five days
yeah it's hard to superset ladies with
something that's the only thing that i
probably won't super set is legs that's
the one the one big day a week i usually
train legs twice a week or twice every
eight days
usually do a three on one off that makes
kind of an eight day split and that's
the one big day where i might be there a
little longer just because warm-ups and
i like to get the hamstrings in first
and then i just i just love leg day to
me that's
it's the foundation of everything else
that i do both you know metabolically
and in terms of my cardiovascular
condition
my physical condition my body fat
uh my body composition seems to always
look better when i'm doing really hard
leg days it's almost like hit training
at the same time as hypertrophy training
so yeah i put a lot into that i think it
yields the most benefits and
um
the rest of it is just you know kind of
maintenance really at this point at my
age and i'm not really trying to do
anything special with chester back
what time do you usually wind down
uh
we try and get the kids in bed by by
nine o'clock and so that's that one hour
after bedtime is usually wind down time
that i'm trying to
tell myself what i preached to everyone
else is to shut the tv off shut the
phone down you know get that blue light
out of your
out of your eyeballs and relax a little
bit maybe do a little bit of reading and
just relax i always take a nighttime 10
minute walk and a huge fan of
taking those walks and sometimes the
kids always want to go
you know
by 8 45 or 8 50. like let's go for a
walk oh yeah yeah they love they they
just love it they jump on their little
bikes though and we just walk through
our neighborhood weather's great right
now for it but uh evening times is the
best time in vegas because it's so hot
during the day we'll go we'll go do that
but it's a family affair now the kids
like to come out in the garage when i'm
training in the garage and show me what
they can lift and
have a little garage gym and it's it's
kind of exciting yeah we have a little
garage gym too and then uh we he he
wants to train with us but he'll like
end up getting the mix like getting his
fingers stuck in the the uh like cable
machine or whatever so we got this
little peg that we stick that sounds
crazy and dangerous yeah like a little
bit like where you put the peg
like the the peg for the cable machine
or what are you talking about so now we
got the bar yes that we have like
hanging off to the side so he has his
own little pull-up bar yeah so like
he'll see us work out and he just jumped
and he's just hanging on it like a
little monkey yeah and he feels like
he's working out too or he'll do like
little air squats and he's just trying
that's all kids needs as long as they
think it's fun yeah that's that's the
foundation of it for them and that's
what i love about like people that train
that that especially dude in front of
their kids or involve like kids in it is
that uh it just becomes second nature to
the kids and they also understand the
dangers of like the gym space yeah
they're either gonna learn the hard way
or they just by you telling them like
hey you got to watch out you can't do
this or just watching it like they're
just taking it all in yeah they only
have to drop a weight on their foot once
and yeah and that's it that's all they
need
i mean they have eight toes but that's
all they need is a learning experience
so one of the things that you're uh
very known for is
hitting 20s on the squat that's
something that you know you always push
and i see all the videos and i'm like i
don't even know if i could hit 20s with
135
what's the philosophy behind that well
when i trained with flex back in 2009 he
had me do a higher volume for
hypertrophy and that's kind of the
foundation of it really he always
likened it to say sprinters cyclists
people who who are who sprint do the
cycle sprints you know the indoor
sprints and stuff and how big their legs
were
a lot of volume with you know under
tension
and he liked to shorten the rest periods
down to two minutes and even in between
sets he'd make me squat down for a
significant portion of time and at full
stretch which was just painful as can be
you can imagine at the end of a leg
extension set when you bring your leg
all the way down at the very end of the
set how hard it is to sit there it's
just screaming at you holding it yeah
yeah god and so he'll he'll make us do
that sometimes after after leg press not
a very fun guy no
and i just you know i just found that
it seems like the hard [ __ ] always works
better than the easy [ __ ] and so it does
just you're so right i get sometimes i
find myself feeling lazy about just
throwing heavy weight on and doing a you
know a three or five rep set it just
it doesn't take me into deep water i
kind of like
uh what that does to me
you know the hit training i see kind of
metabolic
i'll say this the next morning when i
wake up after doing 20 rep squats on leg
day i just feel like i did something and
i look leaner
and i don't have any science to put to
that except for that you know it's a
hell of a lot of hard work and you do
breathe out fat by the way you know you
do it yes you do yeah
that's how fat is that's how you burn
fat you exhale it uh so
i can't say there's science behind uh
you know
you can't sit here and hyperventilate
and breathe out fat but
uh it's just one of the things that that
i've done that it just uh it feels as
though i'm getting a better workout but
more than anything it's just it's mental
it's cardiovascular-wise
uh i wouldn't recommend it all the time
we see a lot of this stuff if you ever
follow like dr peter atia who is an
endurance athlete for many many years he
talks about the fact that too much
excessive cardio can actually be
detrimental to your heart health wow you
see marathoners and the like those who
compete frequently get those enlarged
thin walls of their heart
maybe even experience some endothelial
damage uh which is kind of a precursor
to you know atherosclerotic plaques and
so you got to be careful how hard you
train i don't do them all the time
uh we've had some stories of some you
don't do the 20s all the time not all
the time like once a month i'll do them
um maybe
if not once a week every other week okay
um because i train legs twice a week so
i'll do
so one card one and one just a heavier
workout and a lighter workout the
lighter workout would be the 20s
the heavier workout would just be you
know 85 percent of your 100 max yeah it
does
but if you're doing 20s you're probably
not doing more than 50 percent of your
one rep max
so if someone were to attempt 20s
because i think because i'm a lazy guy
i think good for you babe thank you like
when i trained with mike
uh he would tell me
choose something that you can do for
like let's say 15 reps yeah we're going
to hit 12
but then i'm gonna force reps you up to
20. yeah you know and so
that's because there's someone pushing
me yeah for me if i'm like if i'm going
to hit 20 reps because i don't want to
feel like i'm going to die i'll pick
something i could do like 50 reps up
just to 20 000 yeah what's up what's the
right way to do it like like what is
there a percentage that you're like okay
generally if you're trying to do these
three sets of 20 this is your max that
you're generally trying to choose this
part it should be a hard set of 20 but
here's some of the the things that that
uh to consider
if you do straight reps never resting
just rep after rep after after rep
uh
until until within a rep of failure
that is just as effective as if you do
rep after rep after rep and then stop
and what we call pause reps is
essentially what a 20 becomes yeah at
some point yeah you start taking like
like three seconds three four breaths
yeah it's more of a pause rep
now
that's not any more effective if you
equate for total volume load sets times
reps times weight
drop sets and
giant sets and things like that aren't
any more effective than straight sets
if equated for volume load meaning if if
you just did reps maybe you could only
get 14 reps in a row without pausing and
taking three breaths you could stop
it would be just as effective as if you
did
20
with the pauses
assuming you did the other six in a
different set does that make sense yeah
yeah yeah sets times reps times weight
so we've done a lot of reason we brad
schoenfeld brett contreras and host of
others have done a lot of research on
these drop sets and
supersets and complexes and stuff like
that
and they've just found that it doesn't
yield greater hypertrophy results than
if you just went to within a rep or two
or even three a failure
and then did the rest of the reps on the
next set
so it's more of keeping it interesting
it may have a better muscular endurance
benefit in terms of the cardiovascular
[Music]
impact and so to me it's just a
challenge
you can control a lot of different
variables on a set of 20 you can
how long does it take you to finish the
20 reps
some people will try and do the 20 reps
in under a minute
and then start gradually increasing the
weight over time
and if it takes you a minute and a half
then obviously you're doing a lot of
pause reps
you know heavy breathing you take three
four breaths
but you could do just 14 and your legs
would be spaghetti and you couldn't do a
15th you know without just completely
failing and that's just as good and
that's just as good as if you did with
the same exact weight did 13 reps and
then breathe three times did one more
took three rest did one more took three
rest in one more yeah you did 20 on one
set and 14 on the other
but those other six reps if you get
those in your next set
um
it would be an equivalent result that's
how you like we're trying to equate the
two do you start pacing do you like
already so i've seen people take a set i
mean take one rep breathe two times just
starting with rep number one and just
kind of pace themselves all the way
through or do you just pump them out or
do you try and pump them out but then at
some point it gets to the point where if
if you don't take two breaths you might
pass out on the way down yeah you didn't
get enough oxygen or you didn't exhale
enough
carbon dioxide so uh that's that's the
challenge is can you i always say that
that air is the fuel
you always hear me yelling big air big
air big air because that's what drives
each rep and if you start taking little
breaths
you know you're not exhaling enough and
you're not inhaling enough you're just
not an auction enough fuel to drive the
set so the big problems i had with my
train with flex is he would do a lot of
high volume stuff with short rest
periods and i would get into deep water
and i would be over there sucking wind
and i would be doing these little short
breaths
and flex would come over and he would he
would catch my eyes because you get in
you know you're like you're like panic
you're looking forward
yeah i mean if a 12 year old girl came
up want to kick my ass and be like okay
because you're just you're just spent
you know and it's such a vulnerable
position
and it's kind of like when uh conor gave
his neck up to diaz in that first fight
that they had he was spent he was done
yeah he's like i'm just gonna dive down
here and let him choke me out you can
see his eyes just give up yeah
that that's that's how you feel you're
completely helpless deep water
and i'm not saying that's the best way
to train
it's
i think that what we understand now from
the research is that
um
that you can obtain an equivalent amount
of hypertrophy
in the five rep range using eighty-five
percent of your one-man backs
in the
eight to 12 or 14 rep range using 70
percent of your one rep max
as you can in the 20 rep range using 50
of your one rep max they have equivalent
outcomes when you equate for volume load
sets times rep times weight
the fives will make you a little
stronger 20s will give you some more
muscular endurance but both of those end
ranges also give you more fatigue
so you have more doms and potentially
you know not able to train with as
frequently
and so
really the recommendation is you do the
bulk of your volume probably seventy
percent of your volume for a bodybuilder
in that eight to fifteen rep range
uh and then you throw in a couple of
heavy fives a week and a couple of
twenties a week just to make sure that
you're covering all the bases in terms
of both slow twitch and fast twitch
fibers
and so that's that's kind of generally
the recommendation so
when i say 20s will change your life
it's one part of
a much bigger picture yeah in terms of
setting up your your whole workout
program gotcha do you apply the same
philosophy to
uh deadlift or bench or overhead i would
never do deadlift for that many reps
it's too much repetitive strain on the
lumbar i'm mostly concerned with fatigue
at that point as well not necessarily
injury but when you hit your cns lumbar
in particularly
uh
fatigue increases your cns
overload now you can't train as
frequently plus in terms of bodybuilding
not a lot of range of motion in a
deadlift and we know that that range of
motion is you know as you from your
experience of course with working with
mike israetel uh who's uh been very uh
outspoken lately about range of motion
yeah it's not fun it's not it's not fun
but
you need to to take those muscles
through a great range of motion to get
maximized hypertrophy and and dead
lifting is not that yeah you know it's a
strength movement and so i would prefer
to keep deadlifts and
actually if you intend to deadlift for
competition then
singles you know reset another single
unless you're doing speed yeah and you
can do some speed work under bands or
something like that so
there's a whole lot of
pieces to this puzzle what about bench
or overhead press or pull-ups or yeah
you could certainly do 20s there yeah
and have less fatigue than you would
with legs you know yeah arms stuff like
that it's very pretty easy you need
shorter rest periods and
upper back in particular you can do a
ton of volume for upper back and recover
pretty quickly yeah we use back upper
back kind of as a gpp builder on days
that it's not even back day yeah just to
to get a lot more blood flowing a lot
more movement a lot more volume in
general
and this was kind of the foundation of
of uh westside barbells
program uh which i wasn't familiar with
so i started working with mark bell in
2009 uh and have since read a lot more
about gdp is a huge theme for them huge
things from the left i understand that
yeah farmers carries all that kind of
stuff and also for those that are
listening i know you threw out a bunch
of acronyms doms is delaying onset
muscle soreness cns is central nervous
system and then gpp is general physical
preparedness just in case yeah yeah yeah
i mean the more the more work you do the
more work you can do yeah and i've
talked about that in some videos in the
past and and that you just have to
continue uh to be able to increase your
your volume and to be able to recover
from that then you have to gradually
progress yourself into more workload i
did that somewhat mistakenly so when i
look back in retrospect to my career by
competing in both bodybuilding and
powerlifting i didn't do them together i
would bodybuild for a while i would do
lots of sets and reps and volume and and
create that big gpp base and when i
would transition into power lifting and
i would start decreasing my volume and
increasing my weight increasing my rep
rest periods decreasing my frequency
i would have a big carryover of my
conditioning
into my powerlifting so i would recover
very well and get strong very quickly
when i've got my pro card it was in um
i want to say it was in august of uh
of 2009
i was flexa dieted me all the way down
to it was 250 on stage
uh at probably i was really lean i was
the best shape i've ever been in i must
have been four percent or five percent
it was super super lean wow and i won
that show
i immediately went back and started
training with mark bell in sacramento
seven weeks later i had gained 35 pounds
from 250 to 285 i lost an inch on my leg
because i went from doing all that
volume work with flex lots of muscle
body building volumizing sort of work to
doing heavy singles we were squatting
800 every week for a single
and that doesn't maintain volume but in
such a short period of time i struggled
squatting 400 for reps when i got done
working with flex and within seven weeks
i squatted 850
821 at that meet 8 21. wow what a badass
you're such a badass you don't even
realize how much of a badass you are or
you're just so used to being a badass
that you just glazed over yeah we would
squat 800 every week i'm like damn
klokov talked about this his dad would
make him do a lot of cardio in the
off-season and he hated it because he
would get weaker his dad also gonna jump
into iceland yes that too
but dimitri klokov would talk about then
when he got into his his prep for say
the olympics
he would advance in strength so quickly
and recover so quickly he could do a lot
more frequency uh as he built up into
these heavier lifts because he had that
gpp that general physical preparedness
that cardiovascular-based and and plus
he had uh he had done so many exercises
from so many angles that he had no weak
points he was healthy yeah he's one of
the most aesthetic yeah olympic weight
lifters out there a lot of people trying
to power lift all year round and i don't
encourage them to do that even when i
worked with hof thor and brian shaw i
told him to take breaks not only breaks
from heavy lifting but breaks from how
heavy their body weight remained i
wanted them to cycle
uh their weight as well when i first
started working with hofdor we took 40
pounds off of him immediately
because he had had some some fatty liver
some insulin resistance a little high
blood pressure uh and he just felt like
he was getting fatter not stronger that
was his his words to me yeah i said well
let's drop some weight and that's hard
to tell a strong man or a power lifter
hey let's drop 40 pounds yeah and
they're looking at you like you're crazy
i'm gonna get weak yeah but in
preparation for you know this is a
one-year plan this isn't a three-month
plan yeah yeah and so we brought him
down and then
got him healthier and then brought him
back up uh maintaining his health with
little things like a cpap to improve his
his sleep obviously vitamin d
a little more choline for to help with
the liver
a smaller calorie surplus lower fat
which which
helps prevent
um
fatty liver from accumulating so quickly
yeah uh which you know would manifest
then in the high blood pressure and
insulin resistance and so we kept him uh
i think just healthier and he was able
to put on more muscle and more strength
with less fat
i know you also work with uh
professional athletes do you have them
through the 20s too
you know really yeah
i mean that's kind of bodybuilding stuff
in terms of sports i want them to have
speed strength and so i'm working on
you know explosives getting them strong
which is not 20s yeah and getting them
explosive which is probably not also not
20s so i'm i'm working more on speed
strength
as a foundation for the for athletes
just so it's more sport specific i see
recently um so i know like you know what
the vertical diet why i'm a fan of it is
there's a big proponent of red meat
but i think there's this popularity of a
lot of people uh
uh in taking more organ meat yeah uh
what are your thoughts on organ meat
it tastes terrible to begin with so a
lot of people are selling organ meat
supplements yeah there's pills yeah
beverly international has been selling
you know liver tablets since the 60s so
it's not like it's anything new
the big benefits of let's just look at
the micronutrient content in particular
it's high in vitamin a high in iron iron
folate
liver in particular one of probably one
of the richest sources of of meat that
people are talking about
uh you can obtain those from other other
foods
if you don't like liver and uh
i wouldn't consume more than say six
ounces a week
because now you might be concerned about
getting too high in vitamin a or too
high in iron which might not be a
concern for
most women but for men they tend to run
a little higher in iron
so i'm kind of cautious about how much
they consume i wouldn't use it as a
protein source is what i'm saying i see
people always ask me can i just use
liver instead of you know because it's
highly available in their area you know
we work with people all over the world
and some people have
uh
livers more readily available and
affordable and i would just i would just
suggest that you got to be concerned
although you're less likely to get
vitamin a toxicity from eating it in a
whole food like liver than you would if
you were supplementing it i see because
there's cofactors
along with the whole foods that help
mitigate some of that so i would
certainly be a fan if it was if it was a
micronutrient that you were deficient in
folate's a fantastic one also for the
liver
for the liver health choline and folate
together are fantastic for liver health
but you can't obtain that in high
amounts from say
beans any kind of bean i like lentils in
particular because they're low low gas
beans are hard for me to digest
beans beans magical fruit more eat the
more you toot
it's not good i'm proud of it but my
wife's not would you
just say you would maybe get the same
benefits then like someone that is a
very organ based
diet person versus if you just got red
meat and maybe a multivitamin that had
some of the same micronutrients you
think that's like possibly i'm not a big
vitamin guy i just the research doesn't
support it if you're eating whole foods
uh they've had some pretty significant
studies large studies uh that unless
you're deficient
that vitamins
just aren't much benefit yeah you never
you can't it's hard to replace a good
diet yeah but if you're having a bad
diet then i guess supplementation does
help there are things that are hard to
get from food vitamin d is one it's not
really a vitamin it's a hormone
and the other one is magnesium it's kind
of hard to get enough of it because a
lot of the foods that are high in
magnesium also have anti-nutrients that
block magnesium absorption so yes that
could be kind of difficult those are the
two i recommend that most people
supplement because they're so beneficial
and so hard to find in foods in whole
foods yeah and i i gotta say about red
meat because people always start
squawking because you know about uh
people's impression of red meat and how
it's been maligned by vegetarians in
particular i love red meat i don't care
and pita vegetarian yeah i just say that
we want an assortment we want obviously
enough protein yeah you're saying don't
exclude red meat because when you eat
chicken red meat's three times higher
than iron six times higher in b12 nine
times iron zinc
it's just a superior source it's a good
better best scenario it's not that you
eat all red meat either we have salmon
in the diet because you need omega-3s
there's not a lot of omega-3s and red
meat even pat even
pasture raised and finished uh red meat
is very low in an omega-3s people always
talk about it has more than
than conventionally uh fed
uh but it's salmon is 200 times the
amount omega-3s you could not get a
sufficient amount of omega-3 from red
meat irrespective of whether it's green
finish or grass finished um
and yogurt is another huge one for me
pretty easy yeah pretty easy for most
people to jazz dairy in general has been
shown in in a lot of major
epidemiological studies to be cardio
protective
and and
people have low lower all-cause
mortality when they consume more dairy
um great for calcium in particular is
what i'm chasing with dairy and some
people can't do milk anymore i used to
be able to do a gallon of milk a day in
my 20s i could never do that now you
tooting again
back then i probably didn't care but
you know i could consume a lot more milk
back then than i can now and lactase
enzyme obviously is a limiting factor
there
but yogurt has a lot lower lactose and
has uh the
probiotics and the digestive enzymes to
help uh and then you get into like say
cheddar cheese which is very low in
lactose but calcium not just for bone
health but for
nerve contract or nerve signaling and
for muscle contraction and relaxation
sometimes people end up with
like
their legs get tired and heavy legs
going up and down the stairs
and that's because
they might have a calcium deficiency and
calcium if you follow muscle physiology
you know that the calcium is what's
released from the endoplasmic reticulum
to trigger
uh the tropomyostropomin tropomyosin
uh signal that then contracts and
relaxes the muscle fibers and that's the
big thing is a lot of people when they
get cramps they might have the
contraction but not the relaxation
and so you start getting heavy legs
maybe restless leg at night and a lot of
that could be calcium you could like
twitch in your eye sometime that could
be a calcium deficiency so we think
calcium is pretty important so you got
your red meat you got your salmon you
got your dairy you got your eggs because
the the yolk is so full of you know
biotin and choline and
k2
so i have an assortment of different
protein sources so it's not just kind of
cover everything all red meat yeah but
my protein source is usually ribeye
sirloin and new york yeah that's pretty
good
sometimes i throw a t-bone in there for
like you know yeah i'm not covering all
the bases and people get worried about
saturated fat but if you're eating a
gram of protein per pound of body weight
and you're trying to keep
uh fats my macros my suggestion is about
30 protein about 30 fat and about 40
carbs and if i'm dieting for something i
would probably bring the fats down first
i don't like to get too far under 25
percent now you start getting hormonal
issues and just getting tired and yeah
things like that testosterone
uh and if you're eating say a third of
your total calories in fat
and
most of those protein sources that have
the fats in them
such as steak
are about a third saturated fat
let's say top cereal instead is five
grams of fat and 1.5 grams of saturated
fat it's less than a third
so if you're just looking at ratios
thirty percent times thirty percent
you're down to nine percent saturated
fat
as a as as a percentage of total
calories which is well below what the
american heart association recommends
for saturated fats if you're concerned
about saturated fat if you have a
cholesterol issue a high ldl it's
usually saturated fat that drives that
not cholesterol consumption itself
cholesterol has
more recently i think
most people recognize that it's been
removed
from as a nutrient of concern from the
dietary recommendations so cholesterol
that you consume doesn't seem to
translate into higher cholesterol in the
bloodstream your liver manufactures a
thousand milligrams of cholesterol a day
so it'll just increase or decrease its
cholesterol consumption based on your
concern what you're taking yeah but
saturated fats seem to prevent some of
the
uh cholesterol
from leaving the system
so and that's
that could cause a buildup as a result
of too much saturated fat in the diet
and it's individualistic as well some
people don't have that that issue i see
i'm learning so much
i'm about to sit in the front and just
take notes that's why we do blood tests
i want to look at my lipids and i want
to say what kind of interventions can i
yeah wow
the next question from a fan is um
so you've done what you've wanted to do
in bodybuilding
and powerlifting you're in your 50s
which many people would
would say it's past your athletic prime
but you still look like you're in your
prime like what keeps you training your
ass off still i love to train that's why
i started
you know that's why i fell into it when
i was 17 years old in college yeah i
said i just love to train and so i'm
real cautious i say what's the best
exercise the one you'll do you know
what's the best diet the one you'll
follow
i'm not prescribing somebody to do an
exercise that they're not going to enjoy
and not do
i like to encourage them to find some
sort of exercise that involves
resistance some sort of mechanical
tension yeah because i want them to
retain their lean body mass we know it's
a it's an organ of longevity uh it's a
it's a sink for glucose in the system to
help control blood sugars uh it's been
shown that people who are stronger later
into their years have uh longer
lifespans and so it is it's protective
of uh you know times where you're ill or
you fall or we know that slip and fall
for elderly people is that's the worst
yes it's osteoporosis for old people too
100
and and that's the important thing about
osteoporosis it's not a calcium
deficiency necessarily it's a lack of
tension on the muscles so you need that
tension that's why
you can feed all the calcium and protein
you want to um
to a
an astronaut that's leaving up to the
moon and they'll have bone mineral
density loss and muscle loss because of
lack of tension there's no gravity
and so we you know try and encourage
folks to lift weights you know well into
their
elderly years
and i'll continue to do that i don't
have any you know powerlifting goals per
se
that i'm thinking about our bodybuilding
goals i just love what i do and i do it
in perfect health now and that wasn't
always the case when i retired from
powerlifting i kept trying to do some of
the things that i did i'd go in and try
and heavy back squat you know often yeah
and i had knee issues and i had hip
issues and pretty severe i've done some
videos talking about chronic tendonitis
in my knees for 10 years wow
i rehab that i do i'm smarter about
my training now and i i do it with with
you know you see me walk out and squat
600 pounds with no knee wraps on i have
no pain i enjoy it if i had pain i
wouldn't do it i'd find a different
exercise you know yeah yeah but all the
things you see me do in the gym i do
without pain that doesn't mean that next
morning i'm not sore yeah
but i know it's a good pain i've lived
that way for 30 years if i wasn't sore i
felt as though i was i didn't train hard
enough so
so now right so like when you began it
was because the
it that switched happened or that
addiction happened because you're like
whoa i'm transforming my body right but
now you've you've transformed your body
but now what is it that you're just like
that this is this is what's keeping me
going is it the weights going on yeah
conditioning is more important than
anything i i just love the feeling you
know arnold schwarzenegger talks about
it you know like i'm in the morning i
come at night
and you know then i course i start
looking at other role models than power
lifters and bodybuilders
you know we mentioned mike o'hearn you
know there's somebody who set the bar
very high
and has maintained extraordinary
condition and so i look at that and i'm
like well why not me you know and i look
at even well beyond that i look at
robbie robinson his training partner
who's what is he in the 70s now with
sickle cell anemia and still looks
fantastic and trains every day and it's
not about how big he is or how strong he
is it's his level of conditioning and
um you know again the muscle being the
organ of longevity when i see robbie
robbins and i see
somebody who i think
will not only have a good lifespan but a
good health span will be capable into
his later years and you know the kind of
guy who can get his own luggage out of
the
you know out of the overhead compartment
in the airplane yeah you know there's
just certain things that you'd like to
be able to continue to do
as you age uh rather than being you know
dependent yeah yeah
so the next one uh clearly this guy is a
intellectual
uh from mr oscar
is eating ass a great source of protein
like
i have to say i don't i don't know about
that one i'm proud to say i don't know
about that one you know
i mean there's clearly there must be
some uh some amino acids that you can
only get from the anal region
yeah but i i don't know
just don't be there
sometimes we don't know
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] from calvin dao
you don't even have to say their names i
know but i mean some of these guys you
gotta recognize them their their
intellect uh what are your opinions on
slow reps versus fast reps
you know this has been studied as well
schoenfeld's got a hypertrophy book out
that i mean you just follow it it's the
bible they've done so much research on
this
if the rep is too fast
it's not going to yield hypertrophy
response you have to be kind of cautious
and
they they kind of put a range in there
those 10 second negatives aren't any
better than a normal
repetition so just a couple seconds down
a few seconds up there's
it's really a matter of personal
preference at that point uh there's no
they can't identify any significant
benefit but to say that too fast or too
slow probably not as beneficial as an
average rate like an exaggerated extreme
yeah i see
okay that's good to know
i've been [ __ ] up sometimes yeah what
are
the best practices to maintain joint
health when lifting heavy for the long
haul which i think you'd be the best
person to answer this one yeah well
first of all i wouldn't lift heavy all
the time you're gonna make sure i think
you cycle that uh
and use lighter weights
um
you gotta be careful what position that
you put like shoulders like low bar
squats you'd be cautious how much that's
how i tore my rotator cuff not benching
but from low bars heavy squats too often
um that's when you're light squat day
are they both low bar or do you do like
a high bar on a low bar or i might not
even use a bar i might use an ssb i see
a bar or do a leg press or a you know
hack squat or something
so it's really going to depend are you
are you putting your body in a position
whether it's wrists
elbows or shoulders under a low bar
squat that's one of the primary drivers
of elbow pain and shoulder pain really
not benching necessarily although that
that could be a contributor
um
i would say this that you have to
be cautious about your progression you
don't want to be doing
too much load
or progress load too fast
or repetitive strain
that gets you you know too many
repetitions like we talked about skull
crushers over and over and over again
tendonitis it's not a place you want to
be so
nor do you need to
because
you know lifting weights doesn't need to
be an endurance exercise
and it probably not isn't optimal for
any sport that i can think of in terms
of endurance yeah you'd want to do your
sport for endurance and you'd want to do
the weight lifting to build
strength
beyond that there's been a lot of
research done on passive therapies
versus active therapy i've said in a
video of mine
things that are done to you or for you
are never as
effective as things you do for yourself
and we see that a lot now where people
are getting things like cardiotherapy or
gouache or massage
they see mostly
a placebo effect from that you feel
better yeah but there's no plausible
physiological mechanism to suggest that
you have improved your recovery
uh from those interventions those
passive modalities
the
um
the research suggests that just simple
movement this is even for lower back
pain
simple movement is more effective than
an intervention physical therapy
chiropractic
so move
move a lot move it often it's one of the
things i like about the 10 minute walks
three times a day when my knees were
really bad
one of the things i would do was
recumbent bike
and i would
i would do
40 seconds of a decent pace under modest
tension with 20 second rest and repeat
that 10 times it was a 10 minute
knee workout really
and i would do that three times a day
frequency being more important than
quant and duration or intensity i would
do that three times a day i did this way
back in 2009 when i was training with
mark i had i put one into my little
extended stay i was staying at when i
was living and training in sacramento i
wasn't recovering from workouts very
well i was laying around sleeping a lot
and i would just wake up just
crushed yeah tired
beat
so i started putting the bikes in i
started recovering really fast blood
flow blood flow blood flow
so in terms of if you've had an injury
uh you need to eliminate the source
which doesn't mean that you can't keep
squatting if let's say squatting was the
issue you might have to shorten the
range of motion and lighten the weight
and then continue to do that and i say
uh oftentimes that your body
lets your body dictate the the process
you know the rate at which you can
recover
um then you find a pain-free movement
and you move often
and for me that you know whether it's
recumbent bike or walking or something
even with shoulder repairs you know
people get a shoulder surgery if they
don't do the proper rehab which is a lot
of movement they get frozen shoulders
yeah so it's the inactivity
uh greg knuckles refers to it as
kinesophobia when you get an injury
somewhere you stop moving yeah well what
happens when you put a cast or a brace
on your ankle
small
the atrophy and the range of motion yeah
you lose mobility impairs you lose
mobility so you get a college football
player a professional football player
and they twist an ankle
the very next day or that same day
they've got them in an underwater tank
or in a suspension harness walking on a
treadmill moving the ankle yeah
my pops had a hip replacement surgery
and the very next morning they had him
on a walker
and yeah and they were walking
you have to move the joints yeah yeah
yeah for a few reasons the to get the
blood into those cartilaginous
structures there's there's no
innervation there's no uh you know blood
vessels going into those joints
uh it has to go through through uh
through a pressure gradient right yeah
well that happens a lot better with
movement the
the blood can get in there better rather
than just passively sitting there
there's very little pressure created
also
um
the lymphatic system takes
the waste
uh the debris away
and the lymphatic system doesn't have a
pump like the heart
and so movement is what helps
that
then all of that swelling and
inflammation
to start to be uh taken away and
processed every time i had tendonitis
i uh like if i get grassed in or other
like forms of passive treatment it never
feels as good as if i did like a prehab
movement like you know like tkes with
like like a band and they're just doing
like force into twenty sit and hold your
knee like this and swing it yeah a
hundred times and that actually makes it
go away yeah which is almost
counterintuitive cause you think okay
this hurts from moving so i don't wanna
move and then you go get a treatment and
like you're getting massaged or whatever
but then actually being able to move it
a little bit more with a much lighter
load helped it yeah and there's no
evidence that stretching helps with
injury recovery yeah yeah there's no
injury evidence that stretching helps
with
injury prevention pre-workout there's no
in
evidence that it uh that it helps with
uh post-workout reduction of doms
there's just not
a lot of folks get upset when we have
this conversation because they say well
i did this and it worked well here's
what you have to know about pain
management and there's a lot of this
stuff comes from barbell medicine's work
they do a great job of this and from
lara mar mosely's work out of australia
explained pain is a book that they wrote
that's fantastic
and that's that i think upwards of 95 of
pain
resolves itself
within four to six weeks
uh spontaneously
irrespective of the intervention
and so if someone says oh i went to so
and so and and you know
and now i feel great it's like well
spontaneous recovery is a thing you
could you could have put a copper
bracelet on your wrist and done nothing
else
and you would have attributed the
recovery to the copper bracelet because
that's what you did whether you went to
a pt or a chiropractor or did gouache or
did uh ice bath or did you know you name
it you name the modality where you just
sat there and did nothing
and you will probably have a relief of
your pain within four to six weeks
spontaneously that's why i wish i had
been in that business and not the weight
loss business where we have a 95 failure
rate yeah
recidivism is you know within three
years is is well under the 90 percentage
so i have a hard time having these
conversations because people get all
upset you know i don't know what [ __ ]
you talking about you know yeah yeah i
just stretched the hell out of it and it
fixed itself and it's like well
either that or the doctor that they go
to is like hey you're injured stay off
of it yeah another bad idea yeah but i
mean that's still being
told and like i said like by doctors
that people trust and they're like okay
well my doctor said you're not a doctor
yeah so i'm glad you're saying this
so here's someone that's very very
naughty uh oh another one
they said um
istan ticklish
yeah good question my pops used to
always i do the same thing to my son i'm
always poking it and just hearing him
laugh just yeah lights up your day but
yeah the best thing in the world yeah
same thing my pops used to do to me all
the time so he's counting my ribs every
morning that's how i wake my kids up
if i the the first video that's on my
phone right now is that good morning
song that wake up song like when i play
it for my kids and i start counting ribs
yeah i'm cute i love people
under feet yeah yeah
i love particularly my son well i hope
they got their answer there
uh what were
your parents like were they fitness
oriented were they naturally built were
they super strict on you no pops is a
little guy he played tennis in college
he was 155 pounds he's uh 5 10 5 11.
he's very difficult though he follows
some sort of regimen like physical pops
is uh he's an intellectual he was um
he's a mensah he's he was an engineer he
ran the that means he's like a certified
genius right yeah he ran the dittmer
control center which was the nuclear
power plant for bonnieville power up in
washington my sister was the same
valedictorian of her college head of the
critical care award at johns hopkins
somehow it missed a kid it did not
sorry those guys
like my pops is 91 years old now and
i'll go in his room when he's watching
jeopardy now and he can't even see he's
got uh macular degeneration so i got him
this giant like 80 inch screen in this
huge chair that's like
two feet away from and he's like this
watching the tv
he'll answer all the questions on
chapter probably cheating watching
reruns yeah yeah i got to leave him like
i'm out of your pops so
yeah
what was the question see no you're fine
no you're fine
uh like what what was yeah and were they
strict on you uh
yeah
i i don't know i i
my pops uh i earned every weapon i got
and he missed a lot he there was a whole
lot i got away with too but uh but they
were you know they were attentive both
of them pretended parents not a
stay-at-home mom so she was always
around because it's hard to get away
at our house yeah tell your dad when he
gets home if anything the discipline
just comes from my personality i'm
really type a i'm just like
just like my daughter's that way
i went into a parent-teacher conference
last week and he said you know i looked
over it one day at your daughter she's
in gait she's a great ahead in math and
reading and stuff and she's doing
fantastic and he's like i saw she was
crying and he was immediately i was like
looking around i thought somebody did
something to her you know even yeah yeah
and that moment yeah he was getting all
upset and it's just she didn't
understand the problem and if she loses
at anything she gets oh
so i was like that i was like that i
would i was wrestling in high school if
i would lose a match yeah i'd be out in
the hallway crying i'd be just pissed
you know you're just angry yeah yeah you
know how did i lose failing yourself
yeah so i guess bodybuilding was a good
sport for me being ocd because it's so
regimented and so disciplined and
consistent and everything you know all
your days accounted for and you have to
dump everything into it you know so it's
probably a good choice
that's a good answer
what misconceptions in health and
fitness
would you do away with if you could
uh
i think the big one we talked about uh
is
people think that they need to eat
certain
over-restrict their foods
it's a calorie equation yeah first and
foremost and the adjustments that you
make are really for satiety and energy
uh but beyond that whether you're high
carb low carb all the research shows
that when you equate for calories and
protein where you put your carbs and
fats don't matter you don't need to
intermittent fast
78 of successful dieters from the weight
control registry eat breakfast yeah you
know those are the people who have kept
over 60 pounds off for over six years
that's the largest study uh performed of
over 10 000 successful dieters 78 of
meat breakfast so you don't need
intermittent fats you can if if you
enjoy that and it works for you you
don't need to go keto carbs don't make
you fat
so i think that would be one big myth
and that really the purpose of that is
not to know sibo people into thinking
that the only one particular pathway is
is viable because if it doesn't work for
them if they don't enjoy that and they
can't adhere to it then they just give
up because they think that's the only
way you can lose weight is if i skip a
meal or if i you know get rid of carbs
that's not the case so i think you do
people a disservice by not giving them
more
options that might better suit their
uh lifestyle and personal preference i
think that's a big thing and then the
big one is the over exercising
telling people they have to go crush
themselves and run a half marathon or do
40 minutes on the treadmill every day
more exercises not equal more weight
loss it's not a good
measurement we tend to overestimate our
calorie or our exercise calories burned
anyhow
and so i think it's you do them a
disservice because if you create a
training regimen
that's
too hard or unenjoyable or too tiresome
then they suffer from what's called um
compensation
uh like you go do a crossfit class and
you come home and you sit more and eat
more because you're just beat you know
that's hard work yeah it's not for
everyone yeah and it should be enjoyable
the best diet the best exercise is the
one you'll do it should be enjoyable and
sustainable for you i love lifting
weights
i can't encourage everyone to lift
weights if they don't enjoy it i would
encourage them to do something that that
they love that they loved and
potentially created a little bit of
mechanical tension some sort of
resistance you know within
you know the sport that they enjoy or
the activity they enjoy because that's
so good for for stimulating muscle so
those are probably the two big myths
uh that are out there now that everybody
seems to be battling gotcha so this is
the last question and it's a juicy one
yeah um so to get to the top
tier levels of bodybuilding you have to
cross over from the natural realm to
enhanced
what's like the most proper way to
get into that like the healthiest way
the long the like having longevity and
all that well first and foremost i'd
suggest you compete in natural
federations i would never encourage
anybody to take testosterone unless they
were hypogonadal
um
because there's plenty of natural
federations both in powerlifting and
bodybuilding that you can compete in
yeah we there's you know we
most uh i think most notably is like
lane norton who's done both yeah
professional bodybuilder and um and a
you know a world record power lifter
uh
best of my recollection i think he set
some some records in powerlifting as
well
um who's also you know extraordinarily
smart and has built a great career in
the industry without the need of
steroids um
at the time i was coming up
there was no
nothing other than
than bodybuilding there wasn't physique
figure
you know now you can have smaller
guys yeah um both in terms of weight and
height and so the divisions are you know
there's lots of divisions you can wear
board shorts now yeah you can wear board
shorts
uh i would also say that it in many
cases it's a it's uh it's a life
sentence you cannot start and use
performance enhancing drugs for an
extended period of time and expect to
retain those gains
and possibly to even retain your own
physiological production of testosterone
to the level that it once was it may
permanently be reduced not even if you
cycle off the right way or right way boy
that's a shotgun
i'm telling you that's it's really
independent individualistic is to see
how you respond you get to use in
performance-analysing drugs for more
than say a couple of years
the likelihood that you'll regain
your original testosterone levels pretty
slim uh and i don't know that there is a
right way i know they talk about post
psychotherapy with hcg and clomid and
and those kinds of things is it because
your body goes yeah i mean we don't need
it anymore 100 let's just stop there's a
feedback loop yeah hypothalamus attacks
pituitary talks the
testes luteinizing hormone follicle
similar all of that is a feedback loop
you shut that down long enough and
i'm not really needed
so that's a concern
and even if your testosterone levels do
come back uh you will lose a significant
amount of the the gains that you made
and psychologically they can have a
bigger impact than physically
physiologically
on you know how you perceive yourself if
you've identified yourself as that guy
yeah and suddenly you're not as strong
you're not as big you're not as defined
which might be unachievable uh most
natural bodybuilders you know or
what are they
165 175 you know unless they're taller
they might get up to 195 pounds
you don't see them at 230 240 250. you
just don't
uh when i was coming up in bodybuilding
that's all there was in the heavyweight
class was 250 pound guys you know for a
six footer that's what you needed to be
yeah yeah 250 lean
so uh
it wasn't all or nothing for me those
are decisions that i made
uh
but if you do i would say this i would
say use the least amount possible uh to
effect a result you don't want to go
zero to 100 you're going to go zero to
one and one to two
and you want to be very careful to
manage everything that i talk about in
my vertical diet book
to mitigate damage
look your liver health your kidney
health your blood tests
your sleep obviously
and
some of that has to do with the type of
drugs that that you use injectables
obviously don't have the
two past system to liver so the orals
would be something you'd want to avoid
as much as possible or maybe just
take it to trash your liver it can trash
your liver yeah and your blood tests
have to identify that uh they also crash
your hdls your lipids start to get
affected
and generally can raise your blood
pressure
uh also micro dosing is uh very has
could become very popular and something
that you know we've known about for a
decade or two
i mean you don't take huge doses once a
week you start taking smaller doses more
frequently and that
keeps you from having the peaks and
valleys that cause a lot of these other
reactions in the body
so there is a there's a host of things
that you can do to try and minimize
the damage i think
you know how much you use is obviously a
large component of that you don't need
a ton
to get significant gains uh if you're
consistent over the long term
your body doesn't build muscle like that
it doesn't build muscle fast doesn't
happen like that and so
it'd be the same thing if you said
you know
if you're currently eating
3 000 calories and you woke up tomorrow
and said i'm gonna eat six thousand
he's gonna get fat yeah you know so
body doesn't build muscle that fast it
needs a consistent stimulus is the the
main thing so the same thing would be
true with performance and drugs you're
not gonna your body doesn't have the
ability to produce muscle at that rate
a lot of it would be water retention
and there's a host of other side effects
that
people usually confuse
side effects with effects
and they start to think oh this is
really working
and really what they
you know happened is they got a ton of
acne a ton of water retention
side effects that provided them no
additional uh hypertrophy strength or
muscle gains yeah so what's um
so like it sounds like you're more
uh like not for it like try to do as
much as you can naturally first is there
a scenario where you think it it lends
itself to be
for people to be more inclined to cross
over
that's where you get into the catch-22
where
you're not going to achieve a particular
level into a sport that you want to get
i see yeah without them yeah uh but if
you take them then uh you might also
have a compromise of health or
um you know be popped by
you know a testing organization if one
exists in the sport that you're in yeah
that gets to the point where you know
people are getting potentially paid
millions of dollars yeah it's a harder
decision to make so it's kind of like uh
like a cost benefit analysis depending
on and then you have to be
aware and okay with the decisions that
you make a hundred percent yeah
that having been said if if you are
careful i mean the hrt uh is very
different than performance-enhancing
drugs or intension drugs would be super
physiological doses of multiple
compounds
hrt for those people who are hypogonadal
i deal with a lot of clients in their
40s and 50s
are hypogonadal of testosterone you know
under 200 that you know have a host of
of the associated symptoms
you know depression
muscle loss ed
those kinds of things
it's i would highly recommend you go in
get a blood test
and start working with a good
practitioner
just cautious because a lot of those
folks prescribe things that are
unnecessary in many cases and
anti-estrogens can be a big problem
hcg when it's kind of hit or miss as to
who it works for
i would just start with one thing and
use it long enough
with proper monitoring to see if you're
getting
the benefits that you desire it's and
it's not just a number
you know there's a range on the blood
test but it's not just the number it's
it has to be associated with
side effects
or
i wouldn't say side effects i would say
would be associated with problems like
ed
uh or
you know if you have a loss of energy
you know how's your sleep how's your
nutrition
there's a lot of times where i'll get
somebody that's that's low t
who also is 40 pounds overweight
uh and isn't exercising
and in that case maybe the intervention
maybe the lifestyle intervention could
help the problem uh if they would just
lose a little bit of the weight improve
their sleep eat a better diet do some
you know exercising consistently in
moderation uh maybe all of a sudden
their testosterone levels will normalize
and so it kind of depends same thing's
true with some women who have
hypothyroid
circumstances it could be
lack of sleep over exercise in some of
those cases
and maybe nutrition maybe inadequate
iodine intake
those are
you know those are certainly things you
should pursue first and uh if you get
some results from that then maybe you
don't need the medications because once
you take the medication it's not that
you know the testosterone therapy is bad
or
thyroid medication is bad necessarily
but it it's just one more thing that
you've got to pay for and continue to
take and
uh you know and then the absence of it
because it does shut down your own
system
uh you're right back kind of where you
started
i see yeah i love that answer thank you
so much for all these in-depth answers
to some hard questions some personal
questions some funny questions
and once again thank you so much some
inappropriate questions
guys
just kidding yeah thank you so much for
coming on our show i always feel like i
learned so much and if they want to find
you
and uh get your book or get your meal
prep where can they find you yeah
everything's at stan efforting
stanfording.com my
vertical diet ebook is on there my meal
prep company there's a link there to get
you over to the vertical diet and order
meals delivered nationwide to your door
uh youtube stan efforting there's a lot
of videos on there i put a lot of time
and energy into they're fun cover a lot
of the information that we talked about
today and then instagram also at
stanford that's awesome and i saw that
your book is on amazon as well and i
also see that it sells out quickly yeah
it was the number one new release on
amazon for the four weeks that it was in
the category and now we're up to number
36 in diet books and so we're climbing
we're uh we're happy just released so
it's good i have the ebook as well the
ebook's a little more comprehensive i
update it periodically and it's got some
more training information the blood
testing information
um some
there's just uh
water cut information for athletes so a
lot of people who read the ebook wanted
a hard copy so we produced a hard copy
but the hardcopy is a little more
mainstream
so it's mostly diet advice and general
health advice but they're both available
that's awesome
thank you so much
thanks for having me guys thank you
thank you and we'll catch you next time
bye